salut aujourd'hui je suis dans mon auto
lib avec les ti et lee dont le numéro de
portable et dans la description
l'exemple on devait faire une vidéo
ensemble on s'est rencontré à la fin
d'un spectacle la première fois et on
s'est donné rendez-vous aujourd'hui aux
buttes chaumont et depuis qu'elles sont
arrivés au bout de chemin parce que
quand je suis arrivé il est très beau
l'application arrivée il pleut mais en
mode mon pote qui pleut alors la seule
solution qu'on ait trouvé pour se
protéger de la pluie cette semaine dans
une auto lib parce qu'elle avait pas un
barillet pas un truc à la côte et j'ai
l'impression qu'ils arrêtent de plus
voir mais c'est tellement merveilleux
pour aller dans le temps même si on peut
plus s'asseoir nulle part ce que la lah
avec l'abus et j'ai l'impression d'être
dans titanic
alors on va faire deux vidéos vous allez
voir celle-ci vendredi on est vendredi
au moment où on parle et on se regarde
toi et moi
la deuxième vidéo qui sera la suite et
qui se passera avec les ti vous la
verrez mardi à 17 heures en deux temps
s'est pas trop mal passé pas trop mal
pour une vidéo fait du succès pas trop
mal tu fais la poursuite parce que eh
oui regardez on a un set up de godin
avec l'apport si tlf laponie et s'il
vous plaît vous devez faire apprécier
avec nous le bruit de la pluie
j'ai emmené un petit carnet quel timbre
de passer une surprise pour toi aussi tu
veux commencer par sa surprise là disons
qu'elle sera pour la fin
maintenant ok s'exile en bloc comme
thème faire appel principe une
prédiction dans ok on la met de côté
ouais y en aura la fin ok dans quelques
temps je faire une vidéo sur comment
faire des additions à 50 années de tête
donc on va faire la démo hockey comme ça
tu pourras vérifier deux fois avec ça et
moi avec ça je vous fais voir au fur et
à mesure les amis est ce que tu peux me
donner
on va mettre quoi ça tombe à 5 chiffres
et en lettres aussi tu me donnes un
nombre à cinq chiffres
alors tu peux me donner des chiffres un
parent si tu veux je les note enfin été
notre intention la calculatrice
on pourrait penser que je vous faire
monsieur 59 1342 342 d'accord un
deuxième 67 891 ils sont 91 40 1657 30
2030 2108 un autre 88 88
ouais 88' 675 675 et alors tu vas faire
l'addition de tous à d'accord et moi
aussi de mon côté je peux voir l'équipe
alors j'ai joué moi c'est pas grave je
vais quand même mettre mon résultat à
moi pour moi c 288 673 qui m'énerve
c'est une cheminée alors produire la
moitié soit autant énervé autant moi
lâche et un stress 1673
jimenez est ce que je peux avoir la
preuve s'il te plaît c'est le super leur
faire voir aussi ouais on va voir oui
oui toute manière vous pouvez vérifier
chez vous tout va bien on est bien de
180 1673 bientôt dans une vidéo quand je
vous dis bientôt ça va être âpre elle
était néanmoins je vous fais un master
class sur le fait de faire des additions
de tête très rapidement est ce que ça
t'a plu je sais que vraiment aller au
taquet sur les maths et sur la logique
donc je savais que ça tag est répartie
on va voir si l'élève a appris ce toit
d'élèves
ah bah oui oui je me permettrai ce que
je peux lire à voix haute pas évidemment
fabien moi aussi je te fais une
prédiction un ton tour va m'agacer 2
on va se marrer correct commerce et les
bonnes vannes et lee a pratiquement
talent est assez énorme
ou que voilà merci j'aurais pu faire une
prédiction
comme quoi tu allais préparer une
prédiction moi j'ai une tradition
d'accueil sadi vous verrez la suite
mardi et moi je vais voir la suite dans
quelques secondes merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo si ça vous a plu ce
qu'on a fait avec kelly et si ça vous a
plu que je l'agressé un peu n'hésitez
pas à nous faire savoir en laissant
comme elle vous l'a suggéré un petit
mais néanmoins très mathématique en
poussant légalement dû laisser un
commentaire on verra c'est sûr vous
pouvez retrouver élise si vous cherchez
bien sur internet vous dites à la
violence en foot donc je ne vous dis pas
où la lys et de chercher la
schtroumpfette ça fait un peu matrix et
civet de lapin blanc au monde partir
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne venez vous rendez vous mardi pour
la suite avec les ti et sinon rendez
vous demain pour le master class et
dimanche pour l'explication de tours
passent un excellent week-end à demain
11h ciao
oh